the explosive new york times documentary
continues to dominate headlines
with the ongoing case too free brittany
returning to court today
they say i'm crazy britt's latest posts
included this plea kindness america pass
it on but the singer saw no love from
the judge who refused to suspend her dad
jamie
from his role in the conservatorship
court resumes later next month
remember after britney's 2007 breakdown
jamie was given control over both
her estimated 57 million dollar fortune
and her personal life
you bought mom and dad a house did i
hear that yes i did
back in 2001 brittany told us about
sharing her wealth with her parents
a source now tells e.t jamie worries
about her spending sprees
her team believes jamie's involvement is
very much needed
but a lawyer for brit told the judge
she's quote feared her father
get out of her face i mean now the only
thing jamie ever said to me was
my daughter's gonna be so rich she's
gonna buy me a boat
i have to ask a couple of things about
justin okay
of course more documentary fallout many
viewers are continuing to
express outrage at diane sawyer who
seemed only to blame a then
22 year old brittany for the breakup
with jt one tweet
no wonder britney seems so lost we all
betrayed her by allowing that narrative
he's going on television and pretty much
said
you did something that caused him so
much pain
so much suffering what did you do
i think diane sawyer does owe her an
apology
i think the whole world owes her an
apology it's heartbreaking
she was a baby and it's like it doesn't
seem
appropriate to talk to a little girl
with that tone we got no response from
diane by our deadline
another case in the news lori lachlan
et's learned the full house actress will
complete her 100 hours of court-ordered
community service this week
at project angel food a rep for the
celeb beloved charity that harry and
megan also supported last year
tells e.t lori brought excellence hard
work and kindness preparing and
delivering life-saving meals
to critically ill people